And this idea of comparing labels,
we're going to explore
that through an example.
L1 is uppercase L1 is lowercase l1,
comma Comp1.
And similarly L2 is lowercase label l2,
is lower
case l2 which is the level, sensitivity
level of label two, comma, comp two.
So the comparison is going to yield,
what we call what label
dominates the other label.
Okay so L1 can dominate L2,
or L1 can be dominated by L2.
Or, maybe neither one
dominates the other one.
So these are the various possibilities.
So L1, label L1 is your dominate, label
L2 if, level 1 is greater than level 2,
and the categories or
the topics that make up compartment
one contain the topics or
categories that are in compartment two.
So essentially, we are saying lL is
going to dominate if it's higher
sensitive level, and the categories
actually are a superset, or
contain the categories
of compartment two.
It it's dominated then
it's the other way, okay?
So in that case,
label l2 is the dominating one, so
obviously level l2 has to be
greater than level l1, and
the containment that we had before
has to be in the other direction.
Okay, so this is the subset
relation that we have here.
For the two labels to be equal,
of course, each part has to be the same.
So the levels have to be the same, and
the compartments have to be the same.
So if L1 and L2 are not comparable,
and what do we mean by that?
That means it's one of the first three.
They're not equal, and
neither one dominates the other one.
Then we say that they're not comparable.
L1 doesn't dominate L2.
L1 is not dominated by L2.
And the reason for that is, we're
talking about a label having two parts.
So levels are obviously totally ordered.
So you cannot be,
no you're not comparable.
It's not because the levels that you
have within your label L1 and L2.
It's actually going to be because
the compartments are sets, and these
sets are going to be, neither one is
going to be dependent on the other one.
So, they each have some elements
the other one doesn't have, and
because of that, this containment
property is not going to be satisfied.
And, because of that, neither of
these are going to be holding, and
when they don't, then we say that
these labels are not comparable.
So one thing,
if you take these labels and
arrange them sort of what
kind of structure you get.
Mathematics, actually their name for
that structure,
it's going to form a lattice.
And when you have a lattice,
you have the elements that are the least
upper bound, and the greatest
lower bound, and things like that.
So you can always find labels that
will dominate any set of labels that
you have.
So that would be finding an upper bound,
and you can find the smaller such upper
bound, so that's LUB and
things like that.
So when you compare these, instead of
arranging what's dominated by who,
we get this structure
because of the partial and
the total order we have
on the different parts.
The structure you get is
what is called a lattice.